so welcome to the most any Holli CSS
will show you a lot in your life how
many people have actually used CSS grid
before soft but you've heard of CSS grid
flexbox have used before okay so how do
you feel when you're use flexbox right
is it very confusing to move from like
floats to flexbox was it was it very
confusing that's good because flexbox
and grid are similar not the same
because they are used for different
purposes but if you are familiar with
fluxbox grid shouldn't be that hard to
understand
so this lecture has gonna assume that
you have a reasonably good grasp of CSS
and how to have no specificity the
Cascade so all that I'm not gonna cover
I'm just going to assume you already
know this if you happen to be a bit more
obvious on the CSS front the pace might
be a little fast but you can ask the
nice before wearing the blue t-shirts
for help I suppose so actually at the
end of the day right there's no one
right way to do layout so there will be
cases where it's you would still wanna
use floats there be cases where you
still want to use even the oldest the
like other inline block or even
position:absolute they will always be
use cases for those so don't don't
assume they know now that they see I'm
ask you CSS good for everything know
there's contact is everything you really
need to examine the use case that
applies to you so I just want you to
keep keep this in mind so you don't
think of CSS good as a replacement for
anything it's an addition to what you
already know right so if your could
never get to this do you'll get no Wi-Fi
causes shangri-la is very fast no
password needed so everybody has Wi-Fi
right
okay so yeah can you navigate to hear
you know there's a bunch of starter
files that I prepared so like if you
want to write on marker that's great but
in these data files the maca is written
for you so most of the the koi beer I
think just yes and if you have any
trouble downloading just let me know
the can skincare see these are horrible
fun sorry guys
can i zoom I can also record this
javascript guy is review KN dw6
oh there's a oh no zero no I won't let
me keep my sanity
oh [ __ ] oh my god alternative wait five
seconds okay one minute I foresaw this
yeah where's my car sir oh my brother I
love having a Chinese name anyway well I
will go plus one
[Applause]
I'm just drawing fire you are we are not
boogie oh my god everything happening
next door I die
okay we copy writing
well this is a terrible URL we name is
shot bunny
well I cannot see yeah yeah you're doing
something and Niihau need truth - I
cannot
I really can
you watch
there's a cool tattoo
[Music]
unless we went to adjust the resolution
for 769 yeah
uh okay um in the while he's doing on
this right the URL is built only anyhow
D - B then you press down
we know on size
maybe I do
okay and then there will be a download
button so if school meets gourami
that's like here hopefully this will
download a zip file
does he work question mark sorry okay
moving on okay I'll be talking for about
that minutes first
so if y'all still haven't downloaded
like goofy got hollow down on it and
just listen to me in a background okay
so does everybody have ninety actually I
just realized that even if you don't
have nightly Firefox is fine so
everybody has a copy of Firefox right so
ideally you you run all the code and
whatever using Firefox there's a reason
for this specifically the Firefox dev
tools will have a great inspector that
none of the other browsers have so I
will demonstrate this data but so just
make sure you have a copy of Firefox it
doesn't necessarily have to be nightly
anymore but it'd be nice if it's not
only cuz um there'll be more features in
the nightly Edition any text editor will
do there's no NPM nose I don't know
nothing so the starter files you just
load it into your into your browser be
fine you just have to keep refreshing
paper-and-pencil in from you for reason
we'll explain as I go to the examples
like at the back
so before I start right it's a bit of a
story time has anybody work in an agency
before advertising agency
nobody really oh you have good life man
let me explain I used to well you know
advertising agency and in agency as my
first two jobs so a lot of times
especially in Singapore specifically
right
we are not that digital yet agencies in
general so a lot of the times the
designers usually come from print
backgrounds and it's great a lot they're
really rare talent you see those really
nice banner ads or things that assign of
the lorries the very very nice design
ones as I just came from that table
background a really good at Photoshop
really good illustrator that sort of
thing but one thing about this all
designs is that they all static right
there's already translate very well on
the web and when the agencies trying
move towards digital because it's like
the ending nudua they would get clients
they would say okay i need a website or
whatever and you know
oh that's does this think on response if
it sounds good we want that so okay fine
and the designers were not familiar with
the web in general they would like oh
the responsive means I give you one big
one and one little one right so they'll
give you a large so-called desktop
design and it'll give you a mobile
design and you realize that you can't
actually respond safai them because the
elements or the place that they they
don't understand that in order to make
something concorde responsive right the
Mokka actually matters cause a static
medium like Photoshop or sketch or even
just drawing on pencil and paper you
manipulate it directly see it means I
can oh if I was on the other levees on
the Left I'm saying right it's on the
right but but when it comes to web
design it doesn't work that way and
there's this this mental model that they
before anybody explain to then the DVD
get so you get into a lot of arguments
then I this cannot be built like
actually no it's a really very nice
design it just was very hard to be on
the web so I feel that this lack of
understanding of how the browser was the
root of our problems so what I want to
do is I'm gonna just explain as briefly
as I can how a browser vendors elements
on the page if you already know this
then I don't know go browse Facebook or
something
so these graphics you see right here by
this lady called linklok she works at
Mozilla and she does something called
code cartoons and she manages to explain
a lot of computer science concepts not
just for browsers but computer science
concepts using cartoons it's very great
so eventually I'm gonna share these
lights and or you can see them they're
not cut off a little share you but
you're just going like see her stuff is
really very very accessible so what a
browser rendering engine does is right
because HTML and CSS
even though some people might disagree
actually human readable code like humans
can be HTM
GSS but your browser cannot your browser
cannot read all these letters and
numbers you they have to read bytecode
right so what the browser does is it
will pass the HTML CSS into something
the browser can understand then the
browser will then turn them into pixels
on the screen so when the browser first
receives HTML and CSS files right they
will sort of pass each of these pegs
into objects that the browser can
understand so at this point in the
rendering process the Dom knows about
how the page is structured and all the
parent-child relationships but it just
doesn't know how these elements should
look like so that's the first step so
after that it gets to the style the
style portion of the world where by the
browser or then figure out you know
after everything is passed the browser
figure out how the elements will look
like based on the CSS and at this point
the layout engine was off we try to
figure out the dimensions which is the
sizing for each other elements and where
exactly on the page they need to go so
this is this is if you think about it
right when the browser first receives
the HTML it actually doesn't know the
size of other it doesn't know other site
sizing or all the elements it just knows
that they are there so I think that's
the that's the part where non-technical
people don't understand it because they
think that ok I am in design it to be
designed it should be decided actually
no there's a process for the browser to
calculate how these things actually
should be so after that there are two
more processors you get to the pin where
the browser will pin the different
boxers on the screen and this can occur
on multiple layers so it's a bit like
animation where you where if you draw
and you flip things
so all these the painting happens in
different boxes and sometimes it can be
overlapped it can be multi layers so you
can actually change from performance
standpoint you can actually change one
layer with
without having to repin things on the
other layer so things like z-index
sometimes this happens
and finally lastly there's a combo Z and
render step so all these different
layers there were paint but they'll be
render into one image before render on
the screen so before you actually see
something in your browser it goes
through a lot of steps is just
reasonably fast and you can't really
tell there's a reason why whenever you
do animation we always say oh there are
certain things that you can animate and
certain things you should have any mean
because if you animate the layer
properties like the top bottom left
right right you are affecting it at the
third step so you are forcing the
browser to go back to the third step
recalculate everybody's layout we pane
we composite but if you use properties
like CSS transforms and opacity it only
hits the last step so that's why it's
more performant if you only enemy
transforms and opacity because you don't
read trigger the whole layout pain step
so this is just from a performance
standpoint so this X basically how a
browser works just isn't good to know
information eventually it might come in
handy on you I just taught you ten
minutes of facts unrelated to your life
but so I want to explain now is that web
layouts have changed a bit over the
years
when you started no layout and then
there was no CSS at the time so people
use tables cause they're creative now
and CSS came about people started to use
boots because that was only thing you
could use to soft lay things out on the
pitch okay
adjust things on the pitch but flows
actually one meant for layouts floats
were men for to make your text flow
around the flow around your image that
is the purpose of its that is still the
purpose of float but we just managed to
heck flow to to make it do layouts
they're sort of so hot that is so hard
to use floats to make proper full page
layouts that's why when you try to make
a full page layout with floats in your
own mind cut the columns will never be
the same height that sort of thing
because floats themselves were never
meant for it
so eventually people start using
frameworks because somebody
took up the pain of writing all the
correct passes and applying order hex so
we have frameworks like bootstrap
foundation most popular and everybody
okay I'll just let booster and do all
our work and my everybody's website just
started a lot like bootstrap which is
honestly kind of boring so with CSS grid
we now actually have a proper way to do
layout we have a proper way to control
where everything goes on the web and
that's why CSS good a lot of people are
very excited about it because it's it's
really a we finally have a proper way to
do things you know that we've been doing
things anyhow Lee for the past 20 years
and and now we actually have a proper
good way to do layer so there's gonna be
some basic terminology that I will be
talking about throughout this workshop
so let's just get everybody on the same
page for for grid the lines we refer to
each of me so I can tell where to put
things based on the grid lines so grid
lines actually number are going to a bit
more detail later but so these lines are
grid lines and you can refer to them
using their numerical index you can also
name lines I will cover that later but
some gridlines refer to the x and y
coordinates of the of your grid so each
individual track that's where your
stings sit so horizontal or vertically
each single column or row is called a
great track each individual you know bit
is called grid cell collection of grid
cells becomes a good area and one really
how it lets out rip with this convenient
addition to CSS that we never had before
is the ability to define a great gap
because if you have use flexbox and
you've made a layer or flex box and
you've tried to like oh let's we can't
have everything that next to each other
will introduce some margin between it
just is a very complicated and never
seen some people use like oh you must
negative the padding human- the margin
on the parent and don't know pending
what nonsense but now with grid you can
just say great get 1m thanks and then
everything will just magically
have even one angry so this is a really
good addition I feel like if you didn't
want to use anything else I think we get
is enough for you to convert to using
CSS so that I mentioned earlier flexbox
and green very similar concept so it's
based on a container chart relationship
whereby you have a parent wrapper around
all the items that you want align on the
grid so there's always a parent there's
always a set of properties you apply on
the parent and then they are a
difference of properties your planner
chart so a lot of the properties
actually for grid go on to the parent
for flexbox you still in order to create
grips with flexbox you still hit the
child
so they'll be you'll be clearer when you
get to the actual code but this sentence
actually sums it up very well in that
great works from the container in in in
the sense that you need to have a big
picture view of how your layout is gonna
look like from the beginning if you are
using grid on the other layer actually
work on the item meaning I have to set a
width on the item it could be a
percentage it could be a fixed width but
you have to sort control the size of the
items and so cross your fingers and hope
that the browser renders all them
correctly in the correct place so we're
gonna think about the right it's like
for grid you saw think landscaping you
saw a plan out like okay my my oak tree
is gonna be here my Bougainville us I'm
gonna be here and in my okay
it's at a corner you can plan that using
grid with Nia it's all I just throw the
seats around and hope that they grow in
the correct places so I think that's why
green is so much more so much more
useful for layouts as opposed to the
other methods you are more control so if
everybody could just can you not your
the index.html from in the base folder
in your browser I'm gonna attempt to do
this
and I obviously now practice this so
this is gonna be very helpful much my
pressure so uh-oh
Oh No why is my spouse already day my
god it will not look like this it what
eventually look like this but not now
Joe so if you also ideally you should
already have like CSS a CSS file that is
already linked so you can just type
inside and the classes if so very nice
careful that this if you want to type
from scratch
go ahead like not stopping you so it
should be just like an unlaid up so why
I wanted to demonstrate in this
beginning but is the fact that for
inline if you want to create a trick
Club grid using inline block your Styles
all go on to the item right so you have
to define the width of your item so it's
very blur but I use cup 100% divided by
3 to get 3 columns you won't try it's
fine actually you don't can skip this
section float exactly the same also have
to apply a whiff on to each item
calculation is also a step for flexbox
code is slightly different because you
know you have to apply flex to the
parent but for the actual 3 column
alignment you still have to set your
Flex basis to a 3 column set so if you
think about it right lay inline block
float flash all these these columns
right the grid doesn't exist ok
the only reason looks like a great is
because we force the items to line up in
this way there's actually no grid the
grid is imaginary but when it gets those
when you come when it comes to CSS grid
right the great actually real and grid
is the only layer technique that
just a relationship between rows and
columns this is a key difference between
green and flexbox
because blacks was actually only works
on a single dimension meaning you can
set the Flex direction to row or to
column and it will display but in a
single dimension so if it's raw right it
will later one after another but when
you wrap it around right there is no
relationship between the rows and the
columns so to get them to line up that's
why you're forced to apply a with two
inch flex item you're forcing them to
line up but by default the browser
actually doesn't really know that okay
if I have a three column grid right my
fifth item is actually supposed to be
directly below my second item no the
browser doesn't know this we actually
solve trick the browser into displaying
in this way by setting or with but for
great you actually can do that because
the grid is real so I'm gonna cover the
properties on a great container first
because if you're gonna design using
grid that's the first step you have to
define your grip first the big picture
view right so in order to define a grid
this will be the code from here onwards
so I'm going to introduce three
properties in this example we have grid
template column width template rows and
grid template columns and rows have s no
s Noah okay so it's actually quite
straightforward to define a grid and the
synth this isn't what did he do to my
horrid boy I can't see anything
can sear on a burner
PMD uh okay now mine let me just okay I
don't know why you I at be session is
the most poorly run session in the whole
conference
why are here at 9:00 a.m. oh my god I
want to be here I heard you anyway
Jeremy made a for me we are full-sized
200 what say okay we are to be an idea
thanks Eddie
hi son 20 mobis the stop is the screen
issue not my shoe
that says much what gets done I just I'm
sorry Casey you're not
these ridiculous me huh I can't see I
can't see from 5 feet wait I changed no
no I
whoa [ __ ] can I change a color scheme
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah
I have no flow is any honey I see if I
can change out like that theme and I
just directly use the text editor yeah
give me we are we are we are we are we
are actually also go see yeah see all
right we are
sorry everybody are you joking
okay is this visually better in anywhere
oh this one can see mana back
this one's better right okay okay then I
just gonna keep bleep okay okay okay we
are logistical issues okay
okay anywho I feel like way I met wook
-
why are you here
jj-just thank you no problem we can fix
that since the German and having any
holy banks boss I got in da da huh
everybody take a break he's a bit wet
don't use the finger one without sorry
yeah I know I'm broke 100 know oh y'all
come let go I see for what
any bit any bit okay actually net you
need to put the screen a bit closer you
can you move this in front so I think if
you think away and do you not leather
why you be under the rostrum thank you
for this on the rotten decide the top
Oh on the rostrum due to technical
difficulties it's fine on the floor my
my life my life is so nice so clear so
much clarity I was blind and I see Kai
dojo a dojo
good eye oneself Kelsey I know hi yeah
I'm gone do you get him though okay can
you see oh you don't know what ship or
not
oh you want to I can't just go on the
ground they can sit there no I got new I
got new plan
I got friendly restaurants are not for
me my screen y'all don't you see me okay
hear me can lay oh really
can I go back to dust room oh yeah yeah
I mean who nice colors nice Ohio watch
yes yes
yes oh sorry last one sir coffee thank
you thank you boss wanted by Microsoft
again I sincerely apologize for this
haphazard workshop if you ever see my
name as a mentor don't sign up a way
forever take the anger emporium my
mother thing I'm not doing good job my
Marathi a monkey in real life tomorrow
yeah
Hamish man if I guess yeah then either
for me
this kind of people pay to see you and I
will occasionally style
okay okay
Oh swell oh it's girl oh yeah oh wow hey
Chloe hi HDC whoa no it's all wah hey
thanks for the sorry effect guys okay if
you're hanging out with me - longer
because monk yes me you don't guarantee
so yeah think about it
oh yeah well I get I want 4k Moneta it
works yeah it's the best
okay okay
okay so if you are now using at the
first example right so I mentioned the
properties you want to use a grid
template row columns with an S so for
the benefit of this example let's just
do a fixed layout first because you know
easier to understand
probably oh yeah okay anytime in Oh fun
fact if you are using sublime text like
me the latest follow css3 plugin I go to
compare but if you don't have just take
my hand Oh milady
so what great templates row also you
first have to display grid sure I said
the ball can can great okay save refresh
well this might not work properly I'm
past that guys okay rose life coding is
the worst idea on the planet so you
should get something like this and
you're gonna have to follow the values I
use also your can like use your own
values because I mean yeah why why why B
why 150 I have no answer so use whatever
you want you want to use em if you don't
want it to be spend so I can I start
playing around with it it's alright okay
you want it and even then okay no uneven
things like that so is I showed you
that's that's the first that's how you
actually start getting angry so if you
look at the code right yes it's a big
video so if you have three values it's
three columns if you have you know four
values it's four columns is is actually
why I like about using CSS green is
because it's actually visual inside your
code and later they'll be a few a few
more properties that are that continue
this trend of visual noise but okay
let's do need my favorite then supplies
dies doesn't even know about it yet so
your jammies and arrow but once you get
right so you don't really you don't have
to calculate my jeans or nonsense but
the only thing is that for now it's
Universal so you see I cannot say oh I
want this big gap to be one end is on
the b2 am NOT yeah I think is coming
soon that you can define you may be able
to define the column Greek gap but for
now cannot for now it's just overall gap
yeah for now it's Austin for now for now
event I think it's going to be updated
soon so there is the most basic grid
that you have okay moving on what do I
plan so you can also name grid lines
because if you are
but very early on right I said that
under the terminology okay so now this
is the reason why for everybody to go
and install a new browser if you don't
already use Firefox so if you open the
dev tools for Firefox Firefox has layout
panel nobody else has it and you can see
it will show you every single element on
your page that users display agree so
and the let's - because in the bottom I
have one Mona but let's say if you
happen to define it green C or C or 8
Greece and it allows you to change the
color so you don't get yourself confused
so I say don't I Papa cause the default
value is Papa right then you can change
a color and then yeah so when you turn
it on you can see you can see the Greek
gaps you can see the line number so I
was I thought that only nightly had this
but I was told that even the normal
version has this great display settings
whereby I can toggle on line number
actually I don't know why you want any
of course I always keep it on and you
can also toggle line area names which I
will cover later one thing that the
pharmacy la team is working on is to
actually figure out a UI a proper UI to
display line names but right now you
can't really see line names so the use
case for having grid named grid lines is
that this is a reasonably simple grid
like oh it's just three columns and two
rows and my number only goes up to four
right so imagine if you had quite a
complicated agree that maybe goes up to
like oh I want 20 columns so and if I
want to position something in the middle
I'm like oh that you're not going to
count each of the each of the columns to
get to the lines so what you can do grid
allows you to name lines so the syntax
is square bracket so you can say it is
an to tie the thing on this one name
okay at first time please think of more
intelligent names than me obviously my
IQ is in double like single digits right
now and you there's no limit to how many
names you can name your lines so for
example why does this make sense because
I can like do this so both apple and
empanadas that technically refer to the
same line so you make your code a bit
more make sense
ish give me a foot that starts with C
cranberry you got my fruit man okay long
cucumber cucum a lot fun
it is a ridiculous example okay you you
want to be able to see this on their
toes because not there eventually
Firefox is gonna push update whether you
actually can display the the named lines
is just from a UI perspective it's a bit
tricky because if you have funny people
like me who name give like five names
and all the names are very long or call
hippopotamus there's very hard to
display nicely so I think they're just
thinking about that for now so what we
can do after we've named great lines is
when you place your item I will cover
this in more detail later when I cover
properties on the great item but usually
you would go with you would define
exactly where I want I want item F to be
here like I will refer to it as like 3/4
so it's like start and end position so
instead of 3/4 I can say cucumber stack
cucumber and that's the purpose of named
lines so you can you keep this in mind
pass will use it a bit later keep in
mind that you can name your grid lines
okay so let's move on oh this is an
example okay let's just play with this
example no we're showing this my
goodness
no not this one not this one any money
great too so if you are not in the
layout panel you can actually highlight
the grid and if you can see when you
zoom as you can see this week or 14 you
can click here turn on so you don't have
to go to the layout panel you can do it
from here you just click this war for
icon yeah so they all turn on this so
you can see so if I change this to gamma
and then my items see just stretch the
whole line so I don't have to use
numbers I can use names the
demonstration moving on so other than
naming the grid lines I can name green
areas so I gosh turn this off so
right in this example I have four
columns and two rows let me turn this
thickness up
great
okay come on so you can see I have four
well my numbers
four columns three rows so what you can
do there's this one more property called
grid template areas so what you can do
is you can name your grid so the syntax
is your syntax is supposed to mirror
your columns and rows so you can see
it's four columns and 3 rows as well and
if I want to have I don't want anything
to be in that particular cell is a
notation so for this particular example
I have three items so what you do after
you name your green areas is that you
can assign these areas to your grid
items so I've preached items for this
example if you follow in your exercise
code your selector is different so you
you your noticeable inspect or something
so you can saw a sign each item to its
specific area so the benefit of using
this is that I if I want to change the
layout maybe if I'm doing a responsive
design and I want to change the layer at
a different point I don't actually have
to go to each great item and write a new
assign a new area for it at a different
video query you can just directly change
the grid template areas and you can see
okay now it takes up for all I want B to
be longer okay I can do this I want C to
pick up I can do this so you actually
only need to apply the change to you can
just directly change your grid at each
different breakpoint for in terms I
think this is most applicable we are
doing responsive design one of the first
example we'll be covering later or make
use of this property but I find it quite
useful for when I'm building dashboards
or web applications because somehow
there's my day job now this is quite
useful because I can sort of assign all
my gray items and then I don't have to
think about my gray items I can just
think about the grid so this I feel that
this makes the green areas property very
useful so that's that moving
okay so the great specification is very
long okay now I'm gonna stand up has
anybody actually read the great
specification before ah very good so
you'll just have to trust me when I say
that the great specification is like I
don't know honey
if you print it is a 100 pages I don't
know that but it's a lot of paper but
what it does introduce is this new unit
called the F are unique and it
represents a fraction of the free space
in the great container so this does not
look good on the slide so it looks good
on the code so moving on name area skip
F R 1.30 okay Oh tree huh okay so for
what we can do is template columns to
see in action let's say 1 F R and then
the last two we make a fix now and you
don't actually have to define rows
one dimension if you need to so I'm
gonna be lazy
I just declare that it the I just
spelled something wrongly so yeah forgot
the most important property everything
only was you've got this maybe notice
very nothing works my bed okay
let me take this take it out okay is
this cosmo i zoom
I was oom I about zoom horn I give it
okay so why did right I have three I've
three items I put them in three columns
my last two columns are fixed there are
300 pixels first column is 1fr so you
just takes up all the remaining free
space after the browser gives okay item
B an item C you each are 300 pixels the
rest of the space I thought it can take
everything so that's how that's that's
the basic premise of it so huh it's a
ratio so I say I decide to make the
second one to Fr then we can see what
happens is that now I don't see will
always be 200 pixels because you know
fixed but now the remaining space free
space will be distributed in a one to
two ratio for item B n I don't see
and people want know why developers have
to resize browser thousand times a day
these are to see effect right so so it
really useful for responsive design
because you can solve your letting the
browser do the calculations for you
you're letting the browser design having
an item should be because at the end of
the day you won't know you won't know
like what is the size of the screen that
your user is using anyway it could be
like very nice TV or it could be my my
very very tiny phone so why would you
want to specify a fixed width and then
you know you you end up breaking some at
some point if you use flexible units
like these even like even percentages is
a flexible you need write itself
let's the browser do the calculations FR
is is is useful because it's more
predictable than percentages percentages
is quite tricky actually because it's
always a percentage of something and I
guess for with it's fine but every time
it comes to high just like 100 percent
high never works guys just don't do it
but you know you have a number of
flexible units our disposal now we have
percentages we also have viewport units
I might talk a bit about it later but
essentially I think that we should be
moving towards using more flexible units
because we're just seeing the
calculation so the browser obviously
calculate better than you right so
that's the FR you need I should go back
to my slice the structure is in the
slots
okay so there are nice things that you
can do
you'll notice this repeat function which
I got to about very soon but um so for
that let's explain this code right in
this it says grid template columns
repeat tree but is 3 2 so if you can see
right the these these pictures are in
the ratio of 3 is to 2 so then you end
up with something like this why because
it's a fraction of the free space
available so when I resize the browser
to the fit amount of free space
available changes and so the browser
will surrender all my elements according
to the ratio so so you can get a fluid
design this way so if you notice right
I used repeat 3
and the pattern repeated itself three
times so that's the premise of the
repeat function which will be covered
later so nevermind we move on to the min
max function first
so min max function adding is really
nice because we've never been able to do
this before we've always only been able
to define like a fixed a single value
for for for sizing so it could be a
fixed of flexible value but it's always
the one value but now you can actually
define a range you can tell the browser
I want my my item to be between this
length and that length which we never
been able to do before and it is really
I think a very useful feature also when
it comes to responsive design so moving
on let's do this I am lazy so I'm gonna
copy you can type if you want to we're
sorry the next one very low sorry next
no guys shiny soft all order
okay so if you can see now right
in this example very similar the first
example is just I said the first column
to me next 200 pixels 1fo so what does
this mean
this means that the minimum width of the
first column is 200 pixels it will not
go less than 200 pixels but if it's more
than 200 meters there just a cup all the
free space available so start reciting a
brother folks see because once it hears
200 right it's not gonna show you any
more so about like then everybody
becomes fixated
so like 200 300 300 so I have overflow
because I forced it to be a hundred but
if I have a lot of space you just keep
going
so that's essentially what the min max
function does so kiddies in mind that
you know you cannot define a range of
values and you can you can do you can
cap it so essentially it's a bit similar
if you you wrote a mean with care but
when you use it together within your
within your column so if you use a mean
we've right you can only kept the whiff
of your item this means we've used in
this context is actually the width of
the column so all the other items inside
that column get affect them like this as
well in case you are wondering like why
do we need this where we are mean we've
next we fry so next function is the
repeat function which I use just now is
to specify a large number of columns or
rows that follow a similar pattern so
it's not necessarily that I can only
only need like I say repeat for 75
pixels that I can only have like one
column repeated 4 times actually a
pattern so let's say maybe you have a
pattern of three columns you're like oh
I want to repeat this wonderful 2fr 300
these three column pattern I want to
repeat it multiple times and I really
don't want to type it multiple times you
can't use the repeat function so the
first the first argument is the number
of times you want a repeater and then
the pattern so you can use this in this
example it's repeat
4:35 20 so you can see is that oh now I
have eight columns I think that's pretty
useful okay so everybody probably on the
side is moving on
so other than specifying the number of
the number of times you want to repeat
again the more step further in letting
the browser take over your design is
that again you want only the browser
will know how how big the screen is
and your user is viewing it so there are
keywords that you can put as your
argument instead of a fixed number like
oh three or four these are fixed numbers
right you can use autofill or Auto fee
they are very very similar in that you
tell the browser that okay this is the
behavior of my my column or my pattern
right minimum minimum with 100 maximum
with go go like whatever free space is
available and then you tell the browser
ok browser you generate how many columns
you think is necessary so in the browser
the browser plus its own size so in the
browser is on like this beautiful
Samsung 4k TV you know that you will
have to generate more columns than if I
was viewing this on my phone so this
example is just show the difference
between the two key words of autofill
Auto fee so when it's Auto feel right if
you look at the amount of free space
available because now the minimum the
minimum width is 100 pixels is that the
the container can contain more than six
and you saw it will respect that I have
actually can have two more columns I see
you again Shirley's
yeah on your key what she turn it on so
if you can see right the browser respect
that you casually fit two more columns
so that gives it like proper definitions
by changing to fit home it just collapse
them it will collapse the empty columns
so I might use auto feet you just fill
out other variables but autofill will
respect empty tracks that's the
difference so this is the most amazing
of using this piece of mechanism to
generate regular grids to me so if
you're doing like image gallery or you
know the very popular like pout layouts
and stuff or like a lot of items right
it used to be that you had to write a
lot of media queries cuz that's a quite
a common design pattern we see like
maybe e-commerce websites and things
like that right so my designer would say
hey I have like six columns can you like
six five four three two one and I know
like technically yes technically yes I
can six five four three two one but I
would have to write a lot of media
queries and my market would be very
convoluted so I used to reject this sort
of design I say you have to give me
proper multiples so like I can accept
for two one
okay I said six three one I cannot
accept five four six five four three two
one no I used to reject those designs
all the time because it was too much
you're still Hecky but two lines I can
do six five four three two one
okay five five five four three two one
because using the autofill keyword so
the autofill keyword right again I'm
instructed for this particular example
right let explain I'm telling the
browser I want to have a minimum column
width of 10 MS and you just browser you
also going calculate like browser go go
ahead
how many columns I need so I look at an
example right and the widest okay I can
fit I can fit five columns so you will
you will generate five columns sure but
if you think about it right if I have
five columns to fit perfectly it should
be 50 amps but even if I go larger five
five columns but not yeah six columns if
you want using grid you you would have
this fixed white space let's say your
container was 55 m/s and each of your
column is 10 amps there'll be these five
m0 for white space it is very hard to
deal with but with the F are unique
because it if there's more than a
minimum tab is 10 M but if it's more
than 10 M you can grow so whenever we
distribute these 5 m/s of white space
equally amongst all 5 columns so we can
see in the example right it always H to
H to the parent without me having to do
additional nas funny Cup then I must cup
no percent if I by 5 plus how many ends
for the to take account for a white page
right no don't need you can just do it
two lines is very clean and it always
edge to edge and whenever there's no in
enough space to fit five columns anymore
I reduce it to fall as ensuring summer
okay there's not enough space for four
let's go to tree I literally can five
four three two one
so like yeah I'm to me this is amazing
do you maybe not so amazing cuz you've
never will agency before but if you want
anything before you really appreciate
these guys just sayin
so that's useful moving on next
oh so fast okay then we have properties
that go onto the green item so the two
steps for using CSS grid is the i/o is
that you first define your grid so you
think about the design that you want to
build you plenty already
so after you define your grid then you
want to start placing items on the grid
so it's like my favorite analogies is a
chessboard you define how your
chessboard looks and then you place the
pieces on your chest but depending on
your design however so the the placement
properties as I mentioned it's using
line numbers that's the default so what
you would do is you would okay this is
very simple I'm gonna turn on so you can
see the lines this is so useful if I
didn't have this right I would mess up
all my designs guy can't see
are you I'm happy your own thing oh here
don't use complicated slides okay so you
can see for this
okay see a line numbers so I am placing
my fruits based on the line number so
for the Apple right start at 4 4 4 5 2 3
so that's how I place everything you can
place your fruits or whatever however
you want it to go but so you actually
just tell the browser where you want
your items to be greet column and greet
role actually already shorthands the
long hand syntax is actually great
column start bit column n so by default
each great item goes into one cell so if
I don't do anything my folks are all
going to obediently take up one cell so
okay okay I lazy to put classes are
youth end child but everybody knows the
ancient one is the first thing so I can
make it spend multiple great tricks like
this okay my first what actually diaper
so you it doesn't have to take out one
cell because based on what your design
is you might have you know things that
are longer or shorter so these values
right the first value is where you want
it to start and the last value is where
money to n so if I don't put anything
the default is the star so and if I
don't put any if I don't play and by
default a cat one cell so that's why the
code Greek column for and Greek row two
it works you don't break anything it's
just you take out one cell spat for for
the column count start at two at the row
count but you are free to soar changed
it on like change the great areas and
how you want
I choose to use the
column shorthand instead of writing out
Greek columns that four great column and
six because I'm lazy so I suggest that
you do it also so other than using the
numbers if you remember earlier on we
talked about named lines so that's where
you can use your name lines as well oh
yeah so that's how you that's basically
how you start placing items on the grid
and how you start building out the
design that you have in mind moving on
oh my card is ready so yeah next
so after okay okay this is gonna be
interesting
when I did this right you see I'm at a
place that Girl Talk and usually most
people don't one like you want to be
able to adjust your hypo like I think
centering is somehow a popular design
concept everybody wants everything
centers I don't know why so what you
have is you have a number of properties
that allow you to align things along
your grid within your green in your
great item and things like that so going
aligning grid items so if you use
flexbox right they would how many people
can never remember justified us what
align does what and so this is the this
is a my own personal trick to remember I
don't know it works for you by works for
me everybody has used Microsoft Word
before in your life
right everybody right so you've also
helped to a justified text in your life
right you know the Bata I'm quite sure
is that not on the right-hand side then
you have the justify left justify Center
the word justify always shifts your text
in along the line right so justify you
just remember edifice along a line and
the only two options only got justify
and align so if justify is this
direction then align massive is
directional and then you'll never forget
is formula if it doesn't this those of
you I don't think on something else so
for me a justified line quite
straightforward but we didn't justify
our line there are three other words
there
condense self and items content you need
to understand how it works do you
remember justify content is when your
grid when your parent container is
larger than the sum of your items
usually this will happen if you have
fixed the fixed column widths
because if it's flexible you just take
out the whole space then this these
properties don't really apply anymore in
terms of positioning so let's say for
example my gris-gris conned a nice 800
pixels I have three columns by each
other 200 pixels so in pota mathematical
speaking if your math is very bad three
times 200 pixels is 600 pixels if my
parent is a graphic sauce and my colors
are 600 pixels I have 200 pixels of
available space so indeed like if you
can see this tiny like imagine okay so
this extra white space you can actually
adjust the entire your set of columns
and rows to where you want it within the
parent so you can like adjust it around
so justify content and align content is
to align content within the element now
for justify self right so if you look at
the color coding the content within the
grid cell can also cause some by default
not necessarily your the content within
each cell would take out the entire
space sometimes you have maybe just one
line and the one line will be like all
the way at the top like that alright so
you can actually align where you want
your content to be within the grid cell
itself then you use justify self justify
self is for the great items justify
content is for the entire collection the
entire grid so to speak and justify
items is just telling order is overall
application to each individual item so
you can make all your B items align you
agree items align to the bottom so items
like everybody all together then self is
for individual
or you can just try to memorize these
paper I don't know so that's what you
can do so in this example you can see
how it looks like justify an align
content can do content distribution as
well so just now I described is
positional alignment meaning I can make
all my columns centers that end but I
can also distribute migrate items using
the justify and align content properties
so for positional two for positional the
values is starts at time n but to
distribute properties you have also
three other properties you have space
between space between means that all
your items are yes they are evenly
distributed but they will they will meet
the age of your parent so that space
between we have spaced evenly whereby
let's highlight the easier to see
and I'm going to remove the great gap so
we are space between right it goes to
the the the the space between each item
is equal and the H there's no there's no
space between the edge of the item and
the edge of the container for even
nearer everything has an equal amount of
space around it so you can see the ones
and this this width is half this
distance is half of this distance
because it's evenly the space is evenly
and then we also have space around space
around this is a half width of there's a
handy tip I'll show you later this is
just confusing the same words so for the
first three those are the positional
values for justify content and aligned
content so stop and and Center will
shift the whole thing space around so I
used two different colors for space
around the mouth space around each
column is the same so it becomes a
double space in the middle but for space
evenly the space is distributed so
depending on your design what if you
want to achieve you can use these three
properties accordingly
yeah okay so this is for justify an
alliance elf
by default the default property is that
the grid item stretch and take up the
entire space of the grid item that you
align so for example in the first
example in the very very first exercise
that we did it was 150 pixels and 100
pixels so that's the start of mangry
item if it was the case that means that
by default the space allocated is
stretch fill up the host fill up the
whole area right but I can also align it
so for this one you can see always the
moment I set a value of stat Center and
the amount space given to my grade item
he was shrink to fit shrink to fit so be
actually only picks up this much space
and she only takes on this much space so
by default is stretched so the moment I
give it a value you are shrink to fit so
force V iolite assignee to start so he
said I put a line cell start so we all
remember a line is along this axis right
so studies at the very top for C I gave
it n so in all the way at the bottom for
D I gave it Center so it's in the center
but for all these three they shrunk to
fit so that's the that's that data
that's what happens when you use these
properties for items is just everybody
all together so if I would if I was
gonna do something like stop everybody
everybody justifies to the stat
everybody justifies to the center so
items is for universal pattern
oh so fast demo never okay great and
your name bring on no need no need great
so the the first example is in the
dashboard ah let me try open it so this
is how it should look if you downloaded
it like it's just like that some colors
on it because I was feeling particularly
colorful when I created this the end
result should look like this hold on
is all she wrote on your knees that's
the end result
so starting winds are gonna think so I
think if you look at your starts water
is perfectly empty yay I know the front
part is just resets
and some colors so the classes set for
you ready so how do we turn it from
nothing to that so the mock-up is pretty
simple just stack stack stack stack
stack oh we want to define the green
first so that's actually that's why I
got pens I'm paper let's just look at
the end result
so on a latch on a large screen right
how would you can you draw this on paper
so how many columns will you use how
many columns we use for you to write
rosy 3 right so it's actually very
straightforward cut you you you draw so
this actually spends 2 2 rows which is
perfectly acceptable so you it's not
it's not for 4 is actually for every
addition you attack them depending on
your design right you have to count the
most number of rows and use them so for
this is actually a 2 by 3 2 by 3 2 by 3
but then when it's less than when it's
like after your smaller nail square so
it's kind of say my portrait ish you
become like this
so like these are columns is straight
for where are you two columns but rows
becomes 4 so that's the difference and I
did it when you draw it out they makes
it easier to planner so what we do is
that's why there's a media query written
already
I want to introduce one but because most
most people for media queries you would
use the with one the with Parrish I mean
with max with that's everybody has soft
seen before
has anybody heard of this particular
media query called min aspect ratio we
are
yeah so this media query I find it quite
useful as well because how your
dependent is is a ratio and the syntax
is it has to be two numbers you cannot
just reassure one there's a syntax thing
but you so you you can the ratio is with
high so let's say landscape would be
something like oh eight five
that's a landscape view and then like
one two so you'll be like one is to two
so this is the aspect ratio media query
so for this particular design right the
moment that it's less than it becomes
portrait more or less a portrayal I
wanted to switch and let's get more I
wanted to be the white one so rather
than actually defining defining a whiff
because I'm not sure what's the height
of my users viewport because sometimes
it could be that is is really short but
we've query we don't know the height I
think this is more useful because for
something like - but it could be really
small but as long as this rectangular it
might still work there something so for
this particular use case maybe we can
use mean especially if you can also free
to use with this is not you know the
paper shape you can do everyone but for
this example I choose to use the mean
aspect ratio media query so that the
let's get in the portrait a layer is
different so for this one because it's a
mean aspect ratio so this can't go the
cover this works for landscape mode and
then the code the default code can be
portrait mode so I cannot remember my
marker hold on okay so we can just
define display grid on the body face
then we just now we already mentioned
that we wanted it to be two columns and
two rows
okay so depending on you
so then I'm not gonna leave me how you
want to size your column me being lazy I
just make it equal with as four rows
right I'm going to introduce a new value
called mean content I will explain mean
condemn very soon
wait let me switch back
okay okay
before after
so another keyword value there green
that green introduce us is mean content
and max content so it just means the
minimum content width and the maximum
content with let me mess around and see
you I can get a good example
main contenders means
so for inline animals right so a line of
text is an inline element the mean
content is actually the length of the
longest word so for my first column and
the longest word is dashboard so you
will shrink to fit until dashboard if I
do next container this line is the
longest miss Donna left left right BA
because I obviously am NOT very creative
you will you will take the maximum
content to size the column
so you want anything know what's
happening okay yeah so these values are
useful when you are dealing with text
content I feel you can think about let's
say there's a particular line that you
just don't you one you don't want it to
wrap but you want that column to always
be able to contain that line you can use
content so for example I want up down
down left right left right BA to just be
a single line if a prime is content you
are the entire that would be the biggest
so you would think that you're taking
that length if everybody else is okay
I'll go extra space but I always fit
this just nicely so conversely for me in
content you go for the smaller the
longest would so everybody else just
read and follow so - but because I
cannot break the one dashboard so what
right I can do what I can I can break it
I cannot break the word itself I cannot
make it like - Bob Ireland de Brignac
cannot the browser will don't do that so
your take the longest would so that's
the difference between me in content and
next content so if you think about it
from a high perspective it also works
hazzah
okay everybody go drink tea Carmelita
the twenty minutes can be an easy 20
minutes I can cover a bud see on the
floor trying to put me on the rostrum
guys okay hi everybody I bet right so
when we left off when we when we left
off we just started finding the grid so
I did he write most of the time when I'm
doing great I will almost always have it
on have this on because
so when we just define the grid right
now it's very basic it's just a grid
I have two columns that are both 1fr
each so what this means is that it will
always be half half of whatever right
and so the dimension the mean content
next content property so it always it
also works for rows so if you if you if
you notice the this is a H h1 I think I
put it as h1 remember can tell can tell
okay it's an h1 so by default the
browser Pro makes it to M the one the
bottom is just a normal browser default
so when I put mean content you wash ring
to fit so I don't have to really think
about how to size the higher my columns
I chose to just you know browser you
just go and fit the minimum height of my
text and and leave it so that's why I
chose to go with mean content and mean
content for the the bottom column as OCC
it would take the biggest one and each
one is being obviously bigger than a P
so you will have to follow that right so
you always fit so you won't get things
overflowing so that's the reason why I
put put these values but then as you
resize this right and cuz this is a
wonderfully white beautiful TV which I
want to steal home this doesn't this is
going a bit too much great a bit too
much for my liking so what can we do for
this I'm thinking like not about my mind
thinking maybe we should cap to kept the
the growth so we can make use of the why
don't we just make use of the min min
max
function and I give it a minimum and
maximum because you don't necessarily
have to use one FRS the maximum if you
don't want to so I just want to give it
a range of growing and shrinking so I
chose these arbitrary values and you can
choose your own arbitrary values if you
want to but the point here is that you
were just growing shrink is everybody
familiar with viewport units like do all
you know a VW is everybody knows right
so again I chose this arbitrarily
because I like 45 viewport units
probably ok as it grows cuz I don't need
to be fixed I want it to be kind of
flexible but not too flexible so ok
everything is a bit too much right let's
go with quite the tee and see how it
looks this is a big reason why I don't
do things like coiner because I like to
call in a like and I can see my
differences okay so puppy iron every
fresh 13 oxen better actually
okay let's go ahead okay but like 20
doesn't know right now it's cause my egg
got cut through the bottom actually I
can also mean container
let's try mean condon
oh no no no no wrong wrong value max
content and refresh hey okay these don't
let you know it I can leave you this I
can leave me this
okay let's try Mexican Bella welcome to
the most anyhow new work show you'll
ever be
so one thing you will realize is that
this one Fri is a lot of free space why
is it not taking up the full length so
an atom like Lester inspecting this
problem this problem irrational like I
said right doing height do it percentage
a song so it's not not a fun one because
if you know t-shirt it is taking all of
his peers but my element only only with
just three hundred so we should at this
here
and height 100% bought the only works
because I already added it into HTML if
you I think if you'd be done I'm not
sure I know I try again yeah if you
didn't edit OHP alright
hi $100 1 so then that's the quote of
using percentages so let's say if we
really don't want to do this right
I can use instead of percentages you
just use viewport units so you will just
take up the higher the viewport
the thing about viewport units is a bit
tricky to man
hi always so it's not relative to a
container it's always relative to the
the the the height and width of your
window so it might be a bit trickier to
manage if it's nested within many
components you might end up the the
sizing might be a bit odd so they still
use cases for percentages and they still
use cases for viewports so I have done
design ways of viewport based but I had
to do the calculations outside by hand
meaning okay this is 50 my container is
50 VW and I want it to be like 20% then
I had the calculations I'll do the next
by hand outside you can do that if you
want to fully viewport you needed I'll
show you a demo of a completely viewport
you need a deal or nets outside but for
now that later for now so we have this
we set up on you max content so the the
layer the grid is okay ready so now we
just need to place the items correctly
what was my end result you know I have a
slide for this come on
okay
we boss - poor statistics we statistics
on the top score and the bottom okay so
for this particular use case right this
is the one where I won't use green
template areas so what we can do is the
reference so the title right on top the
second column we have step 3
let's call it stats aha cause I lazy the
syntax is us each each row is coated the
next one is score then steps again and
then
was these car my god a coin and you
caught anything
that's funny bought and then we can call
this don't know I quite controls but and
again you can name it anything you want
okay go ahead and use like cucumber
however so if you came even though I
mentioned on your right knees
corresponds to this will correspond oh
hi looks literally so in a second right
my steps what they cut the I have four
we are one - Oh something wrong with I'm
missing one row I mean one more one more
ok it one more row because I want the
score to be to be the finger scores well
so actually it's four four rows for us
so because it's four also title for sure
score second row steps we'll spend both
rows but excited own space on the third
roll controls the guy own space on the
fourth row and both Bowen control was
spend two columns so the high looks it
corresponds to this so happy this so
after we've assigned a good template
area right we assign each any month you
put it into its own area using good area
so good area singular not plural no s
great template areas yes Brewer got s so
you have to solve like take note of this
impacts and if it doesn't work right
maybe is a spelling problem for great
area right no cuts just the raw whatever
string input here you can try we quotes
Kosovo so
type type and so I think ideally right
you would like to put your your your
reattempt
areas right um don't make the spelling
don't complicate that cause odds are you
might miss type something and then
you'll be very confused why the job so
don't don't spell things like necessary
or you know what a funny was that
everybody gets wrong right just a
protein
okay how he works so she wrote you fun
from just now refresh whoo yay
y'all get this okay turn around get you
it is anybody didn't get this
no response yes any problem no problem
no problem
great so the nice part about the dev
tools is that you can actually see your
names you can toggle it on and off that
is very immediate it's blocking your
watch I can turn it off but I think very
helpful to have it so you can know if
you assign your area to the correct
place or not and you can also see if
like let's say for example right eye
let's go back to my origin no mistake
right yeah I take away one this I
actually not sure happen
so lets you happen and then you can see
something wrong ready because it looks
really weird one thing that I didn't
mention
just realize it instead of the does
button being instead of bot being being
of the larger area it became the stats
so you realize that it doesn't
correspond to 1 to 2 to y allocated the
thing is the browser is smart enough to
know that if I actually define four rows
right you were implicitly generate one
more row it's just that because I didn't
I didn't define the size of the row
correctly the browser just automatically
define it for me
but it will not break your layout
completely you just make it look weird
anyway let's just make it normal
so this path is set already so what we
want to do next is the one it's layout
that when it's the white layer so let's
look at how the white layer is supposed
to write okay there's an email play
okay nobody's so the layers can change a
little bit this is the one with the
three rows and two columns instead so
what we'll do is we will adjust this to
remains the same so let's find ownio
copy over just copy this over inside
here into your media query okay then we
can start modifying things so it looks
like this so I think we can keep the
columns we just need to change the rules
so let's take out one row
so this works but we were VG will
regional positioning of we're gonna
place each item change the template
areas so now we only have three rows so
now we want tighter up top steps has
moved steps move to this place the
bottom one is score now the bot takes up
two cells here controls maintain safe
everybody can get nice right can or not
no problem ah okay okay so the layout
set so now the issue is alignment so
we're gonna run through how to align
things properly
father we can predict Euler stacks we
are my word this is supposed to be a
game okay okay we wanna send bodies we
understand daddy's tags so of the toy
hey how you Center this in the center
we're getting a look at we do a mock at
home but
okay so based on the alignment
properties that we talked about earlier
how would you Center the house and other
rubbish text I wrote Dana sent out about
anybody like what properties who you use
something or I and I what because they
are three this there's the turn of the
icon okay so we had justify content we
are justify content we have we have
justify self justified ups so which one
will we use
okay so once a content source itself so
what if you don't know right
just try and refresh this is how wet
developers what folks so me will go to
the bot
we try we try the vertical and vertical
axis but aha
a lie content spoiler this is not even
but let's just try it anyway nothing
happens because it's not obviously not
the correct one so we'll do something
but not what we want it to yeah so so
this is the if you if you remember when
I when I shot I kept saying that once
you apply a value to the a line sell
property shrink to fit so in a sense it
is correct it aligns it to the center
but that's not necessarily what we want
because we still won the game bought to
pick up the entire space right so this
is this is why text box and grid I meant
to be used together
so what week
we will still want to use the online
self property just not on its own what
we want to do is we will make the bot
green item itself a flex parent so once
we do this right we can get we can get
this whilst maintaining the size of the
grid item
so the great item is the agree item
still users is default value of
stretching the entire area of the cell
but then we can align items within it
when it itself is a flex parent so oh
you know we just do the standard flex
things that's rare then we want to chain
this so we don't use a line items you
use a line content and then we do
text-align:center
then content so then Center okay let's
talk about this situation when you use
flex I know this is not powerful critter
but xbox relevant the alignment
properties on flex box a little bit
different from great very similar they
said in button the behavior different
because both properties are for
different things so I in a very
beginning I mentioned that flex is
single dimension so in for this
particular case right
when I say flex rep you are ready round
so what a line what a line content does
is that it will align the lines as a
unit if I use a line items it's actually
aligning each sock image unite the Flex
time because I put weave of these 200
right so the next one has to wrap down
so you imagine this a flex line so it
can looks like I have a slide for this
good you got a birthday yeah if you
don't say yeah so how it works is that
when it wraps down right these purple
lines are called flex lines
right-aligned items aligns it along the
line instead of the whole thing a line
content will align the whole thing but a
line items actually aligns along the
line so if it flex when it flexes you
take up the entire height so it becomes
like that this one is very spaced out
when you use a line items it's actually
centering or soba is centering along a
flex line so that's the difference
so that's very useful for this
particular case we use content because I
want the content to be treated as a
whole and center in a center so that's
why you use online content so justify
contentious you're changing stuff
you will be at the left simply because
right this text is smaller than the
width of my entire cell so your shift as
a whole if I did not put
text-align:center you would just be a
left aligned to the left so in this case
the common center everything right I'm
just doing when it's centered you just
move to the center so the
text-align:center is to allow everything
to the center because this is correct is
just that fix at 100% so it doesn't
shift when I use justify justify content
so I'm so to Center everything centrally
right here to send the readings for this
particular item so that's why it's a
trick question and that you had to
actually make this bot green item itself
a flex parent are you're confused no
he's right quickly right great thanks
love you all so for controls how should
we Center the controls text anybody
well you're like they're actually son
not convict it they all just X and I
sent okay now yeah so so that's that's
it yes Nestor
that's how you get the end result so
alignment is settled
it sure what properly my phone is broken
so I'm gonna do this yeah
so I'm assuming we can get this effect
not all caught everything aligned nicely
it's responsive there's the first
example the next example is this I was
informed that this was a very
complicated so we have I don't know one
hour Reseda ha we see how ok so this
particular design cars on their knees
be honest
let's try to build this k2 so the code
is in here and the mockery is no markup
apparently the mark-up fonts and images
preparing these so if you load it you
turn your honor hey why do you
okay nearly how it looks like without
any styling
so
okay this is the most basic of basic
nurse so without any styling it looks
like this so the other day I don't the
mark-up is the mock-up structure is
actually important because if you all
around for the for the accessibility
tour you'll understand the screen
readers actually follow the market order
so you'll want to setup the mock-up in a
in a in a semantic way in a sense that
okay my my h1 my title comes first
and and and I think a good way to check
how cementing your maka is not have any
styles to begin with you just write on
my capsule and you see how it looks like
so this is quite reasonable I feel from
a semantic perspective so first things
first is to get this
how how you break this down into agree
how you divide up everything so that's
what the pen and paper is for with my
fam paper
so let's let us try in Britney's now my
from the results of my planning one two
three four five six iron out with six
columns because let me explain this is
one column this is another column this
probably needs to be another column and
then this artist spotlight will be in
its own column and then this veto is one
more column so one two three four five
six these items right can cause we can
spend multiple columns our item can
spend multiple columns we want to reduce
to the smallest how I planned the
columns and maybe you might you might
think of it differently I'm just gonna
share how I plan the columns right in my
mind is like the smallest component each
having its own column so when I saw when
I see this design this is the end design
that I copied from somebody's driver
short right when I start to plan the
columns I would think that go for the
smallest component so ideally you could
have this as one column but then is very
hard it's gonna be hard to align this so
I would rather have this in its own
column and this full text can take up
two Kotkin can can consume two columns
because this this and this I would like
them to maintain they are they are with
I wouldn't want it to break
I just want it to behave like just I
give it its own n okay its own space but
this this is a length of text that I
feel can grow and shrink so I give this
one its own column and the meeting
for this space actually I check if the
space is on column as well because
eventually you wonder you don't want
this you want it to grow but you don't
know too much you want to maintain a
space at the wider slang so actually you
can choose not to give it so this
pattern this pie is actually optional it
depends on how you want to call out the
design because our original design is
this is full-length they had this very
nice white space but when you think
about it when you compress what's the
first thing that you can compress from a
design perspective in my mind the first
thing that should can be compressed is
this white space because when I don't
have that much space to work with
I wouldn't want to immediately string my
text I want to keep this this length
because it's quite a nice comfortable
like as much as possible so what I chose
to do is I introduced an additional
column technically not necessary but
from a design perspective right I give
it I allow this to be a collapsible
space so that's why that and I end up
with six columns so these are enemies
out I know you can see but it's six
columns one two three free space
one two three four five six I was wrong
bit more actually pop him so five five
is four text you can see because this
line is actually in the fifth column so
this edge e1 is together and this one is
together so a piece policies on column
so six columns then four rows right roll
is a bit more straightforward just four
so one two three four
yeah well I did thank you
so one one for the title two for here
this one tree is on four so it's six
columns for us so this is a bit more of
this this is why you need the pencil in
paper because if you did if you looked
at this of the actually the first part I
didn't come out this
I took me multiple passes so the first
part I she only had four I had I had one
two three four
I didn't come for this part yet but
after I thought about here I'm like okay
the the extra column came in from here
and then for this one right I realized
that I would rather give that order is
on column but if you don't want to give
to a deck on column you can also do that
because by writing this column it can
become one column also depends on how
you want to shrink things so to me when
you do when I started designing radios
or a pen some paper so you can draw and
redraw so like mention in a very
beginning designing layers you CSS grid
you have to have and you have to have
the big picture view you have to know
what you want to achieve at the end of
the design plus up front so it's okay to
plan on paper first
once you plan on paper everything else
becomes much easier because once you
have this one you have got this this
final layout down the rest of it is
actually just tweaking the the the the
sizes like I did that like we did just
now so that's how I got my six for
alignment so let's let's go if the these
six for thing I don't know if I should
just pass this around and you can take a
look I don't know sure any honey if you
want so that's the that's this that's
the six voting so let's start doing it
don't and turn turn turn
okay uh if you are lazy right the spouse
like the actual colors and stuff yeah
you know just go through the finite then
you just copy and paste
I [ __ ] about I forgot but you're why I'm
sorry so just just copy the color since
that was my bed
I mean it's not not greedy not as
non-group unit that I just just got be
over
okay everybody okay so this Widow
Aramark up first so mean is the whole
thing the base styles I got off with is
for browsers that don't support grid so
we we want to solve take care of the
fallback layout first because the other
day they they are still going to be
browsers that don't support grid and we
don't want the layout to be completely
broken
we don't need to be completely plain
also so you just give a very basic
styling so why did just now I copy over
this one is just to cap cap it we don't
want the lines to go to to white we kept
it and Center centralize it that's fine
in order to make your images responsive
just put this is just an that practice
max with hundreds and then you want
overflow okay so this is this is
reasonably decent I suppose and then
what we have is we can do let's do the
okay this is fine pitch one
you know what let's just cut this short
if you look at the the final CSS sure
you copy copy all the way the line 98
and just pace it over already right so
you open the open this one go all the
way down to 98 copy everything I retired
I cannot D so basically I do I do the
supports query so y'all just I do here
halt just replace rebirth everything
yeah I'm sure already beta but because
this fight is not in green eyes just a
fallback so I'm just going to assume
everybody can do this without GUI is
fine right
eleven works it works on on up Remini is
the most basic one is way you can you
get you can see the title you can see
this is kind of decorated but it's quite
straightforward single column nothing
special
then the tour days just kick to the side
so once we've taken care of the the four
back then we can start layering on the
the fancier layout so those as everybody
seen this particular query before I
suppose is this new to anybody have you
never seen a suppose in your life please
let me know they explain why is great so
everybody's familiar with media queries
right
so in CSS the query syntax usually is
like an app so at media is media query
is a conditional so it allows us to have
if-else statements inside CSS so one of
the few things where we can have logic
in the CSS tittle media queries in that
if the query is true then it applies the
styles within a block so for at supports
and supports the the the the term we
call we call them teacher queries and
the condition is within the parent
pieces so inside the parentheses I will
put the property that I want the browser
to test for so the browser knows itself
browser and the browser I know okay I
support wit or I don't support me I
support CSS shapes I don't suppose he
ownership browser knows itself so
browser when he sees at suppose you were
you were you will examine the rule
inside the parentheses and you will
check oh okay display agree do I support
and greet or not if I do support grid I
will apply the styles within a block if
I don't support the grid and I don't
support great right I will not
everything inside the block so this is
good because whatever you write inside
grid you will not bleed up so it becomes
if CSS B is supported then everything
inside
applies but if I don't write it totally
ignores everything altogether so your
base fall back will never break your
fall back will always work you're always
like this even if your browser supports
doesn't support me even you the style
inside the grit will not bleed out if
your browser does not support it that's
how it works that's why it's called a
future query so the syntax is pretty
straightforward is at supports with an S
s do PP or RT s ok and then inside the
parentheses your you have to have the
parentheses if you don't have the
parentheses you will not work cause the
browser will pass for the property
within a parentheses yeah so that's just
that's how it is that's how it works and
that's why we use it the media query
looks a bit complicated so just is a
it's not a lie it's basically a
combination so for me there Croatia you
can change multiple media queries
together you don't necessarily have to
only use one and in total they actually
thirteen properties you can query but
nobody uses all them so does not
introduce one less unknown one mene mene
aspect ratio I think the other things
that color and and things like that but
what you can do is that you can use the
end keyword to like chain like only
apply if both are true it's like just
magic thing so you can use and I think
it is also but I will double check that
and get back to you but for now I want
this to apply when these con two
conditions are met that's why it's there
and as I wrote it for you so you don't
have to think about it so let's go and
see
when but even though the stars inside
don't bleed out right you will still
have to do a little bit of resetting on
the inside consol for the browsers that
do support grid there are some things
that you want to be set that's why if
you look at is easier to go to next with
and padding I said to none these are
resets because for this for bad layout
right I didn't give it I didn't give it
a back Swift and I did give it some
padding but if you notice the this one
is edge to edge no pending and no max
width so we want to reset that when when
we apply great we wanna reset reset okay
we said so that's why they that's why we
have the next we've done and padding:0
is a reset so the next thing we do is we
apply great so after you reset right
so a stretcher so this is the the base
that we work with so then okay let's put
on the grid so just now we already we
already explained through why ahead why
I had six columns and okay this is the
very complicated part that I will go
through why I made this decision so to
make everybody's life easier just copy
and paste guys it's not weird but no
worry that's cause we haven't placed the
properties yet turn on turn on be easier
to see
by default if we do not place the
properties the browser adjust each
animal each green item will be placed
inside each grid cell like top to bottom
left to right so there are fewer okhla
in order if we didn't specify where we
want each of our great items to go
you're just filler in order so that's
why this is based on my markup so just
now my market was no hero hospice then I
have to then carnival was here so on and
so forth so let's look at each of the
columns first column to Fr we leave that
bus
let me separateness
six columns right
who fr is this bit this bit here this I
said into to Fr the next the second
column is for my two-a-days so my tour
dates right like I mentioned I really
don't want it to shrink I don't need to
break so I put a Max and Max content
just to make sure that you always be
tour dates one-line not tour dates and
then I put a cap on how much it would
shrink oh sorry no no no I don't want it
to grow beyond course - this is a very
short it's a very short face please so
no point lady grow and so much white
space so I kept it once you hit once you
hit - a day sure I don't go anymore
but don't shrink so 10 M next content is
to handle this particular element next
line is the same constant for this cause
pen to 2010 Toronto is a bit longer so I
give you a bit more space 14 M but is
the same concept next content so plus it
hits the longest I don't even grow
anymore so this gives me more space for
other things so that's why the third
column is also min max 14 MX content so
now we have the spacer column the spacer
column is mimics 1 M + 1 fr so I
technically could just make it one
effort and if I didn't have the mean the
mean value 1 EV I mean if you wishing
down to 0 but in this particular case I
I don't want there to be a situation
where this this but that just my image
so I chose to maintain a 1 M mean if you
if you're okay with it
kissing the site then just use one
effort that's also fine like explaining
the logic we have to be behind my design
decisions so this column is actually for
my spacer this this and you know explain
fit content
okay thick content is same family as a
mean content and Max content in that the
official official definition is a very
long and computed in my own words fit
content just means that you grow the MS
min max but with regards to content so
fit content means you grow to the you
shrink is mean content then next when I
am so you perfect content but once it
hits you will not grow further than 28 M
but you will you will continue to shrink
as per if it was min content this does
not make sense when I say out loud but
it make sense in my head oh no think of
it as min Max Auto 28 M
how can I explain this in English this
doesn't work okay it will not grow more
than 2 km right the the the call the
column with maximum will be 20 am by
your shrink you will continue to shrink
as per if the minimum was mean content
so I think for this right
longest what maybe for photography it
will by rushing until photography but
you will kept at 28 M so that's for
these specs and lastly is this one this
is spotlight is cup 2m plus 0.5 v w let
me clean myself the h2 if I didn't say
ok here too if you look at the official
what you copy right my font size is is a
variable font size so this again is an
optional thing to do but you can
actually make your font size have a
relationship with your viewport width by
using viewport units as part of your
font size so this day I don't use a set
formula I like I bought it to see what
you want but when you use the cout
function viewport width is dependent on
VW dependent on your viewport width
right so the reason why it's 3 M plus a
viewport unit is that when because
viewport width when I shrink it it could
go potentially it could resolve to a
value that is very very very small so
what I want to do is that I will cap it
at 3 M so once the viewport width value
it's a very small you don't your text to
disappear because if your font size is
like this these are these values right
and the browser's are a were still busy
off to pixels okay when the browser does
auto passing when I say very like the
first thing I say in the mornings and a
brother had to pass all the values right
he will resolve all these like m units
viewport units percentage right it does
at the end of it before rendering it
does pass it resolves to a fixed unit it
resolves to pixels but all these
elements the width of the elements the
the font sizes of the elements they are
and at the end of the day have to be
resolved to pixels it's just that the
calculation is transparent plus the
browser does its own thing
so 3m plus if you use only viewport unit
is possible that you will resolved to
like maybe zero pixels that's possible
the calculation so we don't wanna text
to disappear so we were kept it like you
were even once the viewport you need
zero right you're just be 3m that's the
minimum size you can't so even in my
viewpoint goes any smaller I'll still
keep 3m my tax will not disappear so
it's not fully responsive text it's it's
responsive text with a cap so that's why
there are these values again like I
mentioned I have no set formula
I bought this too so 3m plus how much or
you can adjust you can make it to M plus
8 VW very this is up to you just eyeball
it I set on this week or no over let
look nice same for so same for each h2
you could make this a fixed font size
that's fine also I wanted it to just do
a bit of growing and shrinking because I
felt like it so because I did this one M
plus 0.5 v W for its font size for the
column I made it to M plus 0.5 VW so
that I gave it a bit more space that you
can ship you have a spacing between
because if I made it exactly the same as
the font size there's no space so it's
basically the font size plus a bit of
breathing room
and again this value right is arbitrary
you can change it whatever you like
remember this
is anyhow Lee is based on what you want
the design to be this is so you're doing
to follow my values exactly your if your
door one you can change the spacing you
can change it however but that's my
explanation on why this code exists the
Row three more straightforward so for
the four rows I want this design to be
fully in the viewport so there's no
scrolling and the whole when is the full
landscape view right no scrolling always
fit so I chose to use the v/h/s my unit
so if the math is correct if you add all
these together is 150 so your OSP so
this in a sense this is just ratio ratio
of the viewport unit there's been use
right now so with the reason why I have
a mean height query is that when you are
using viewport height as your units
right you will know what at all Heights
because it's relative to the height of
my own browser window if I did not have
this you will shrink to it will break
there will be a point where this layer
would break so the reason for the mean
we've created be dense the moment in
it's less than 27 ms cost 20 surnames is
where it shrinks and any smaller than
they write my texts were overflow things
were already big so I will choose to not
have this layer anymore this now doesn't
if my viewport height is shorter than 20
cm so for myself the designs that I do
whenever I do this off I want the design
to take up the full height of the page I
almost almost always pair it with a with
a height query otherwise I just don't
don't use the viewport height you need
because it's too variable ready yeah so
that's just a that's just from my
personal experience so that's how the
grid came about so now that we have our
grid right but everything is in the
wrong place so what we want to do now is
you want to start placing items ready so
go back to here
so again let's let's go here copy a copy
mi
so actually these tights all right it
starts from the it starts from the top
column because this was to is first to
second one for tour dates my first one
is for the image so he starts from the
the column so the line is as follows 3
and is 3 to 6 because it spreads this
was spreads all the way to here so
that's why that's why I Street to 6 is 1
to 2 because that the top row so
basically yeah movie moving over to here
ok want to move the hell over here we
remove at this spot like over to the end
here we want to move remove this down
here will move toward is over here and I
move this thing over here so if you
don't use your brain to think then we
should just copy now if you notice I use
this a negative value because the grid
the index is not only so that's positive
index and there's also a negative index
so the use case applies here negative 1
will always give you the last green line
so for example this one is a fixed this
one is a fixed defined great day III
already say 6 columns so I I can choose
to put the last number which is 7 but
let's say you use auto auto fit like the
browser generator however many columns
and you don't know what your how many
columns days you wouldn't know how to
you wouldn't know what the last number
is so what the browser vendors decided
is that will give you a negative index
so you can always hit the last column if
by using the negative one so that's this
that's a use case for the negative index
so I'm lazy to think I say just one most
other sites we just use minus one that's
why is one minus one is the equivalent
of
I'm sorry side column I could have each
seven I could use minus one but that's
the negative index so for role we move
it here so this this positioning will
move h2 to that side
continue going okay I have a HR any
month the hey Simon is very limited
thing but it was this is just for this
thing it's a decorative anyone so if you
do any day you can ignore if you want to
is not technically not important here
are you can stop so HR if I think if you
don't do anything to is just one line it
is one pics or something so you can just
how it I apply background color and in
idea we've I just started to look like
that he is actually not important the
great scheme of things if you want to
ignore it just anyway all together it's
fine and the above is here so like I'm
talking York I assume we are copying a
Koki
so it's just positioning and if you are
wondering for for this particular layer
wide I didn't use grid template area
because grid template area you cannot
overlap if you want to do over let your
design for example my image is actually
from the my image is three columns three
columns but it has to overlap with my
title I cannot do that if I use grid
template areas if I don't have overlay
in my design I have to specify that the
color a row numbers that's the only way
you can get it over so that's why for
this use case no area no names no names
no areas you can name the lines of
course you can but you know I was lazy
so I just use a numbers so that's an
explanation of all the the column and
rows is just to place everything in the
correct place so I'm gonna do my own
coping
charmagne easy your copy raha iodine
copying I just continue explaining my
coat so once you have finished copying a
copy a copy
they are regret Sonia what is any holy
workshop
oh my god the one foot strip Hey okay
his butcher is real actual software
blitz drafting so that's good
not the framework oh my god why is this
my dry food there oh yeah I don't know
what these does okay check
hey Noam it looks like something oh I
know what misery
nomads well done yes you're quite fun
done done right okay
okay okay if you finish copying other
placement code know the position already
everything is in the crepe SEO so let's
the rest is just tweaking position
everything is correct so for this one
here's one right if I don't do anything
you realize that is either a back so you
can do is the what the z-index does is
it brings it back it brings it on top of
the image so that's why I wonder hitch
hitch want to be dead that's why I have
a Z next day we do the front panting
okay margin bottom initial let's talk
about this value initial it's I think
it's from ie I in line on what you can
use initial what initial does is that
you will reset so because I had some
fallback styles right rather than set it
to a value like zero and not having over
idea again right you just said it back
to initial you bid whatever it will be
as if you didn't apply an image in
bottom on the air or then I actually I
quite like using initial for for
resetting instead of giving actual value
right
for any spouse will apply so I think
that's kena you can choose to put it to
0 if you want to as well I suppose so
that's that's why this is there is just
for to reset for backs down top padding
to make it look nice okay let's talk
about this if you show that for my top
yesterday I will I spend like half are
we talking about this so this is how I
mean the texts go do that refresh yeah
then we can already so that's that again
this is me so positioning we already set
another just making it look pretty
he already put in for about okay let's
look at about um about right you are
noticed that it's actually at the top
but in the in the ideal design is
actually to the bottom so what we want
to do is that and this looks nice
this one we don't need to use the Flex
trick because this one the background is
what it's okay if if the grid items
showing two feet cause you can see from
a visual standpoint is fine so you can
just directly do use the align you can
use the align property so when you
highlight it right
you can see that if there was a
background right you have cut off here
cause the the degree item area has
shrunk to fit but from a visual
standpoint doesn't matter because the
bad guys dy anyway so this why don't you
do the display flex ting you can just
align self to the to the end and then
just go down petting and just make
things look pretty it's fine okay so
this I forgot what this did but I
remember what this does this is just to
create this line that's all so if you
draw this line or you're not using image
also cane but though his image I like
you CSS so I just use a pseudo anyone to
create that line so this is no important
either moving on email
location so location is this a great bit
and so this baby is on top it has
overlap my image so this is a open this
is this kind of thing is a trick the
image is at least the rectangle is just
we started to sit on top on the bottom
right corner so how we do that is that
we put in this these these are
presentation styles right so see again
the index to bring on top location
I also watchful much won't keep nonsense
oh my god bring it to the top this one
right
this one we need to do the Flex trick
because it's on background color these
are different background color there's
life on this too even though is the
effect is the same right this one you
don't need to use the flag shake is a
from visually you can get away with it
this one visually we cannot get away
with it that's why for this one we have
the the Flex trick and that's why you
apply the alignment properties to the P
which is here fun fun part about
centering items if you only have one
element within your Flex container
margin Auto will Center it perfectly
don't have to do any justify nonsense
crap just put margin Auto and Eva be
right at the center only applies if
there is one flag for multiple items you
imagine Auto it or not you will spread
things around but if you lay one item
this works so so that's that's how you
get it to the center and lastly this
looks fine for a simple reason because
we have studied in the fallback stars so
these last two lines again are resets to
reset it back to its original value so
that you are seen sit nicely on my grid
so that's that's done ready this is how
you this is how you get the the
landscape layup so okay check is
everybody here okay everybody gone this
right
no right waiting ball right excellent
what else do I do
continue
what what go up go up
open stop no change anything
ain't nothing
why the extra okay can anything about
this I'm doing this very long ago is
this movie it oh okay okay okay
and actually we are done
but why explain is this part if you
didn't choose to do this then is not not
necessary but I'm gonna open the the
actual demo she went down really the
only memory I got I got more examples
it's fine
okay so this is the whole thing so you
know this this black know this is Bella
if I didn't do that okay so it's not
perfect but this part not very nice so
this is the problem in using Newport
Heights for your layout so there will be
a point where it looks funny so that's
why the query work the curvy soft once
my deadline hits right I switch it at
Dorney anymore
so when it when it goes to this this
layout right and you turn down you know
the hinge is not there is a sheet there
it's just that the opacity or set to
zero so it's actually just a visual it's
just for the line this last the last
query right it's just for that stupid
line so if the stupid I was not dead a
query ruining this yeah this is just an
explanation or a good
but anyway
one more thing I want to talk about is
the fact that the image kind of USA
changes so the image actually normally
what you be able to achieve this effect
when you when you do background size
background size cover and content you
you'll be able to sort of change how
much of the image is displayed so
there's a new property called objective
that you would if you copied it over it
should be here on their copy weight so
if your image doesn't do it
where's my object P oh no no you're not
you're not in the top here Oh Jake fit
cover what it does is that it makes
content images meaning the images you
learn into your website using the IMG
tag right you can let it behave exactly
like a background image so it used to be
whenever we could if you wanted to do
this as I saw responsive images we had
to do the we had to apply an image to
the background background image it and
then you background size it then you do
the content cover thing now you can do
it onto content even just as well with
the object value and it takes the same
values you can do cover you can do
content just like bhangra images so
object fit the support is quite good
already just don't think about
supporting ie
because nothing new is going going to IE
anymore people just people just stop
thinking that you will is now just
Microsoft is just supporting in the next
bar as a courtesy to like banks and
stuff we still have to use it so so for
in that in Andheri guy right that's a
that's a good reason why we still use
the for backs so that if you are not
using an older browser is still it's not
broken it's just a bit more plain that's
fine so that's this this particular demo
explained if I try to follow the
structure of my slides okay which I
don't try this or we can try this
because this is actually us CSS then
it's not you can see the you can okay
you know it's quite okay the SVG is for
my lattice cause the phone is custom the
okay had to Flickr CSS animation a my
but the Greek the Greek the bad guy is
agree so so each of this is a good so
okay these are I just thought I on your
if you want to follow you can follow our
there's a pen link does everybody have
the slides or not so I think the link is
there we are
okay something ah Ling Ling Ling so here
you can see the code so you don't I well
we can talk about it let's just talk
about it
I've used this s so that's why there are
variables here but it's just what colors
it's no big deal so when I say
responsive right this is the lister when
everything is fully viewport so if I
resize is always going to feel so that's
one thing but the tricky part about
using viewport units is that so
everything has to be calculated on so
for this particular case right is fine
but when I applied it to here this is
not you have to convert everything you
have to convert everything back to
excuse me otherwise you just for this so
here right all the values will add up to
100
okay that's fine but what if you want to
use it as a component as part of another
like video as I cannot 100 anymore oh
that's where you probably want to invest
in a calculator or if your mental sons
are really good you have to ratio
everything you have to ratio everything
to get it get it to fit into this size
or you perform for me for this
particular are changing to a fixed but
similar is actually quite
straightforward why why do I have to use
grid for this is because let's see we
can find
well I got I suppose everything oh my
god so okay the great template Rose is
straightforward because there's only one
row the columns are calculated so that's
how you yeah actually it is Jesus to be
example because all you do is for I do
is do this okay let's not look at
details to be example I'm sorry let's
forget it is a nicer example
yeah I agree this
mm-hmm okay this is why I really like
the green inspector too because even you
transform the grid inspect our transform
with you yeah so if you wanna do funny
things idea you can see use that you can
still visualize using the green specter
Torah so a sauna so for this right each
of the the origin the the base imagine
if I if you don't have enough spatial it
doesn't make sense to go diagonal
because diagonal actually only looks
nice if you have a widescreen so that's
why for this the the transform only
kicks in when it's diagonal that's fine
but to tune it out it's grid so this is
actually the header on one of the css3
at Aqaba he was an image so because at
the point in time I was fun employed and
I had nothing well doing my free time
and say okay let's make this in CSS so
what we can do is a design like these
will work because all this you can use
other properties you you we mentioned
before and just play so you can just
place everything as sm when wherever you
need it
and
when you see this right the first thing
to do is to design something like this
right
you have to plan it you have to although
what is in the planning so I'm going to
see if I can find the original image
then we can talk through the great
planning process cuz it really any Holly
workshop
so when you first scene is the reason
why I felt that you could be done in CSS
be is because this these numbers they
look like they were equally spaced and
then it's not exactly aligned but these
are these individual elements that can
be spaced out along with because the
critical requests also long it follows a
grid so based on this premise also okay
let's try to let's try to start to plan
this so we know enter code again the
original the the base grid looks like
management green
you migrate and suppose not here nine
columns so because it's diagonal right
you clearly on the original you can
really see the rest but you know you
probably just put it in with because
when it's when it's this way you do any
empty so how much do you got do you went
out do nine so okay no nine so we do
nine that s the reason why point nine
columns because the original design sane
is so that's nine so for the roads right
and this is fun because if you don't
back at the design and close this you
can see can't see that okay
how do I want to play me this looks like
UK actually socks make these three
elements they seem to be very like
regular space so again I have a travel
even with two M so the first tree is to
M because I knew that if I use the
alignment properties against off like
make it an even but the grid itself can
be can be the same length for the for
the text itself right I went with a
min/max well with min Max value because
I changed the the site to to match my
phone size and Allah the last to this
one make it even and the rest this VPP
is just to make sure that it's a header
is a header height because of the Diagon
Alley when you do diagonal is a bit
tricky because the whole thing flips out
of the viewport so you actually to do a
design like this
you have to imagine if your designer
gives you a design idea you actually
have to imagine what happens here a
dress is gonna arrive in our blank
spaces so that's that's how I came up
with these arbitrary values so again if
I
this Sakurai
the only reason I went with two Emmys
because after Bo trying error he was how
this sucker over land underneath so for
this book the ranges are against Allah
eyeballing you can and you play around
to change the values of the room but
once you have set up your green right
it's really just a matter of placing
everything in the correct place and then
you can start styling all these kind of
funny things for example like things
like this are pseudo elements this is a
pseudo element the the blue circle is a
pseudo any man with a body all all these
funny decorations are just pseudo
animals let's go and see so this one is
the beef is a before and then
you when you see those elements you can
do a lot of these decorative effects
without having to put additional markup
into your into your into your HTML
because these are purely generated by
CSS so it doesn't pollute your HTML
button you get you can see make it look
pretty so at the end of the day right
for we're gonna do all these kind of
funny things with CSS I think it's worth
keeping in mind when I I call this a CSS
grid workshop but I realized that there
are a lot of properties in addition to
CSS grid to make the designs work so
other things like object fit la see you
know any month things like that right so
I feel that CSS is a bit different from
all the other programming languages and
things like that in that is not more
doula is is that is the type of is a
tough language like a language it's a
language them you need to use many
things together to get the full effect
so even though we when we teach things
we teach them individually as a module
when you apply it when you apply in your
work when you apply to to design things
right you have to keep in mind that is
how you combine all the different
properties together to get the end
result so there are many ways to do this
you can easily use a background image
for this yes.can or you can do it with
CSS you can do is you door elements so
for CSS right is a bit more flowy and I
think again that's the reason why I
think some people the very very strong
variant programmers for me the guys in
the next room right probably don't like
CSS very much because it's a very very
different way of thinking is it's like
it's really everything is a global
variable and I think a lot a lot of pure
software programmers just think that
that's a horrible it's a horrible thing
uh but my my take on it is that CSS is
not a programming language it is its own
thing it is a it is a star-shaped
language that
requires us to manage this whole global
variable space and I have no shortcut
for this other than experience because I
mention a lot of things I bought like
even when I went through the the - box
and everything I had to save and look
seven look safer no and I don't think
that's a bad thing according the dice
part but I really wouldn't wouldn't
wouldn't do it as a we work when we
design a CSS yeah what else can I say
basically as you can see now I'm feeling
time right cause this is this and the
past but earlier than I I imagine okay
fun things we can do is CSS oh yeah okay
I had this event like 2 days before J's
calm and we had a banner and let me tell
a story on the banner let me show ya
show your benefit me first we must I
sincerely apologize for any help of this
project okay
yeah next I see my nindo saya okay don't
don't don't sign up he's a better idea
by deorro No
my chrome is broken open firefox not me
okay so for for all the other
promotional SS Aveda someone asked me I
need image I will just screenshot this
because this this is built using CSS the
story of this is that I wanted to use
this phone this particular phone is a
web phone so this is no image I can copy
and paste it is such a vertex but color
phones or pot is not it's not supported
in Chrome is not supported in Safari Inn
is supported in H so hello
so only H and Firefox support this so
what was going to happen
but color phones is one of those
properties that falls back well because
is not as if the phone one load so this
is Safari
if you don't support a phone just gonna
be black so the long story short is that
all the image editing programs that I
could have fought did not support color
phone so I wanted to design my banner
iver
I couldn't get a nice California shop
because he only works in the latest
latest latest edition of Photoshop and
as a funemployed bomber radicular for a
subscription and the pirated version
also didn't support this so in the end
after okay let's let's just use the
browser to design this so this is the
banner that got printed so how this
works is that and this is this is a
trick in case anybody wants to do
something as ridiculous as this right
this is a good use case for viewport
units so how do I get the dimensions
correctly I'm using a Mac 13-inch from
2015 so it's 2x density so if I do 100
VW when I screenshot on the whole thing
the resolution is about two thousand
eight hundred eighty and somehow the
cost of the printer need are a bit
larger eighteen either I don't know
three thousand or something and you
think oh cannot because that's the
maximum I can go actually know what you
can do is you can go beyond 100 if you
go beyond 100 and you catch a screenshot
right it goes more than that this is a
this is just an accidental discovery so
you don't you're not limited 100 that's
why right now for this particular thing
right is overflow which is fine because
it's more than the viewport width and
more than the viewport height is
overflows it still works and if I print
in cos Firefox has this like take
screenshot
function okay so that's it bye everybody
you can go in fully yeah but if you want
to do badness you can do this trick okay
thank you good night